[Musik]
der schwere weg aus dem shutdown
politiker und fachleute loten aus welche
lockerungen wann möglich sind vor allem
bei den schulen hoffen und bangen in
norwegen nach dem schweren erdrutsch
trugen rettungskräfte bisher vergeblich
nach überlebenden und pleite am
schicksalsberg karl geiger chancen auf
den tournee-sieg schwinden in dienste
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesen ersten sonntag des jahres sport
gibt's auch in etwa acht minuten mit
norbert knobel
bund und länder werden übermorgen aller
voraussicht nach die korona
beschränkungen über den zehnten januar
hinaus verlängern
offen ist bis wann und was mit schulen
und kitas passiert eines ist klar die
bisherigen anstrengungen haben nicht den
erhofften erfolg gebracht von neun
wochen am 2
november die ersten neuen maßnahmen
seitdem früher restaurants cafés kinos
müssen wieder schließen
kontakte beschränkt werden am 16
dezember dann die verschärfung die
weihnachtsferien werden vorgezogen fast
alles macht dicht doch die
infektionszahlen bleiben hoch andreas
cüppers noch mindestens einen monat
vielleicht mehrere bleibt der deutsche
corona winter so trüb wie eine schlechte
videoverbindung uns geht es darum dass
wir handlungsfähig bleiben indem wir bis
zum 31
die zehner gemeinsam zusammenbeißen das
robert koch institut meldet heute 10
1315 neuinfektionen 312 menschen starben
in verbindung mit dem virus
diskutiert wird vor allem über die
öffnung der schulen über die die
kultusminister morgen entscheiden wollen
wenn die gesamte gesellschaft mit
deutlichen einschränkungen leben muss
dann ist es wahrscheinlich dass es
solche einschränkungen auch in den
schulen und kindertagesstätten geben
wird den vorschlag vor allem für jüngere
klassen die schulen schon ab 11
januar wieder zu öffnen sehen die länder
skeptisch die besonders hohe
infektionszahlen haben bremen hamburg
und hessen sind eher dafür
lehrer verlangen die entscheidung allein
vom infektionsgeschehen abhängig zu
machen
das ist die klare aussage daran müssten
sich die kultusminister halten und hier
habe ich ganz scharfe kritik geäußert
weil einige kultusminister meiner
meinung nach hier die sache etwas zu
locker zu leicht dazu einfach so
während das gesundheitsministerium mit
seiner kampagne für das impfen beginnt
deutschland kein pc hoch für die korona
schutzimpfung wächst die kritik an der
impfstoff bestellung sofern muss man
leider sagen dass lag bei europa soll
jetzt kein vorwurf sein aber die
ergebnisse sprechen einfach dafür dass
zu wenig impfstoff besorgt wurde und
dass das management etwas zu kleinteilig
war
deutschland braucht mehr zeit mehr
impfstoff und etwas mehr glück könnte
auch nicht schaden
noch haben sie die hoffnung nicht
aufgegeben nach dem schweren erdrutsch
in norwegen suchen die rettungskräfte
weiter nach überlebenden
bisher vergeblich sechs menschen konnten
sie nur noch tot bergen
am tag vor silvester waren nordöstlich
von oslo in der ortschaft aus erdmassen
ins rutschen geraten
mehrere häuser wurden komplett zerstört
hermann bern berichtet auch die
königliche familie besucht heute den
unglücksort um mit rettungskräften und
angehörigen zu sprechen
in ost war die erde auf breiter fläche
abgesagt mehrere häuser und wohnungen
wurden zerstört einige gebäude um bis zu
400 meter verschoben
helikopter thronen und spürhunde sind
seit tagen bei der suche im einsatz
mona top und stenmark teheran um wurden
in der nacht mit ihrem haus in den
krater gerissen und blieben wie durch
ein wunder weitgehend unverletzt
es dauerte stunden bis zu ihrer rettung
es war erschreckend und das dauerte so
lange ich blutete und es war so
schrecklich kalt
wir würden da noch hilferufe
und konnten nichts tun wir stecken ja
fest und waren warfen die ursache für
den erdrutsch ist weiter unklar
die suche nach mehreren menschen auch
zwei kindern geht weiter die angehörigen
einer vermissten 13-jährigen schildern
die dramatischen minuten
ich dachte an ein feuer und rannte aus
dem schlafzimmer ins treppenhaus an
magie und victoria waren vor mir
ich dachte sie kriegen die tür auf als
ich unten war brach das haus zusammen
die beste schwester und nichte der welt
ich liebe sie und weiß nicht was ich
sagen soll
in aus gedenken die menschen der opfer
des unglücks kerzen überall in den
straßen der kleinstadt diesel unter
einem euro benzin nicht vielmehr diese
preise sind wohl schnee von gestern denn
die neue co2 abgabe macht
klimaschädliche kraftstoffe teurer
für berufspendler gibt es allerdings
einen steuerlichen ausgleich was 2021
auf autofahrer zukommt zeigt jutta sonne
bald für arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer steigt die pendlerpauschale
von 30 auf 35 cent für die einfache
strecke zur arbeit ab dem 21 1 kilometer
wer sich ein neues auto anschaffen
möchte muss beim großen spritschlucker
in den sauren apfel beißen
je höher der co2 ausstoß desto höher die
kfz steuer die kfz steuerreform ist er
ein reförmchen also der unterschied
zwischen sehr hoch imitieren den
fahrzeugen die suvs und klein sparsam
leichten fahrzeugen
der ist nach wie vor zu gering wer
zukünftig sparsam mit dem eigenen auto
unterwegs sein will der sollte sich
frühzeitig für ein elektroauto
entscheiden
für autofahrer soll es leichter werden
auch in mehrfamilienhäusern private
ladestationen sogenannte wall boxes
einzubauen
der kauf von elektrischen fahrzeugen
wird weiter gefördert bei reinen
elektroautos mit bis zu 9000 euro
plug-in-hybride mit bis zu 6000 750 euro
gaffer werden künftig härter
sanktioniert wer unfalltote fotografiert
oder
muss mit einer geldstrafe rechnen oder
einer freiheitsstrafe von bis zu zwei
jahren
noch sind ferien aber schwimmbäder
museen kinos theater hotels alles bis
zur zeit zu kein wunder also dass es die
menschen scharenweise ins freie in den
schnee zieht trotz aller appelle und
ansteckungsgefahr in deutschland greift
die polizei ein in der schweiz kaum
david sauer
der berg ruft im schweizer kanton
graubünden das land lässt die meisten
seiner großen skigebiete offen solange
die kliniken noch kapazitäten haben ohne
abstand im gondel schwitzkasten das
schreckt viele nicht die gondeln sind
doch genau so voll wie öffentliche
verkehrsmittel das ist eigentlich das
gleiche da mir ist schon bewusst dass
das nicht die beste idee ist und auch
guten skifahrern kann jederzeit ein
unfall passieren die spitäler haben im
moment ja schon genug zu tun
die schweizer corona zahlen sind mit die
höchsten in europa deutsche touristen
müssen bei der rückkehr zehn tage in
quarantäne
mit weniger panorama aber ohne
quarantäne suchen viele das
schneevergnügen im eigenen land heute im
harz am letzten tag der weihnachtsferien
aus dem alltag ausbrechen gegen den
corona koller im schritttempo werden die
verschneiten mittelgebirge seit tagen
überrollt hier in winterberg kennzeichen
aus allen teilen des landes jedes freie
fleckchen wird zugepackt die polizei
sperrt ab und beklagt dass hier massive
verstöße gegenüber der krone
schutzverordnung auch festgestellt
worden sind und deswegen sind wir um
amtshilfe gebeten worden lifte und
hütten sind übrigens geschlossen heißt
keine toiletten kein aufwärmen und keine
rettungsmannschaften und jetzt tun der
sport norbert wird wohl wieder nichts
mit einem deutschen sieg bei der
vierschanzen-tournee sieht nicht so aus
also der rückstand der herren
eisenbichler und geiger ist schon
ziemlich groß weil sich ein polnischer
springer einen großen vorsprung
verschafft hat kann jetzt doch gewinnt
in innsbruck teil 3 der tournee und kann
am mittwoch seinen 3
den gesamtsieg perfekt machen
könig camille dominiert am bergisel zur
freude seiner polnischen teamkollegen
sprüngen auf 127 ein halb und 130 meter
katapultieren olympiasieges doch an die
spitze der tournee wertung der bisherige
führende gerade gut aus norwegen patzt
im ersten wird heute fünfzehnter und
fällt auf gesamtrang drei zurück
jetzt sagt ich bin eher ein blöder berg
und schwacher erster sprung auch für
karl geiger er wird in der tageswertung
sechzehnter und hat nach innsbruck als
gesamtvierter schon rund 13 meter
rückstand auf doch das ding ist so gut
wie durch und das ist einfach
frustrierend
markus eisenbichler ist nun
gesamtfünfter die chancen auf einen
deutschen tourneesieg schwinden
im ersten sonntagsspiel der fußball
bundesliga gewinnt dortmund gegen
wolfsburg mit 2 zu 0 der bvb jetzt
vierter der vfl hinter union berlin 6
doppelerfolg für die deutschen
rodlerinnen am königssee julia taubitz
fährt beim weltcup auf platz 1 von
natalie geisenberger die im siebten
saisonrennen zum siebten mal zweiter
wird aber im gesamt weltcup vorne bleibt
1 sieges küsschen von julia taubitz sie
gewinnt das rennen am königsee und damit
die generalprobe für die dort
stattfindende wm in vier wochen
der bereits fünfte sieg der wm zweite in
diesem winter die deutschen rodlerinnen
überlegen olympiasiegerin natalie
geisenberger drei zehntel dahinter auf
dem zweiten platz
sie wartet damit weiterhin auf ihren
fünfzigsten weltcupsieg eine heim
niederlage erlebt die deutsche team
staffel mit knapp zwei zehntel rückstand
müssen sie den fehlerfrei fahrenden
österreicher den vortritt lassen
das wetter hat definitiv noch luft nach
oben morgen zeigt sich die sonne nur
ganz im norden und auf einigen bergen
ganz im süden
südlich des mains und an der nordsee
bleibt es trocken sonst fällt etwas
schnee im norden auch regen minus zwei
bis plus vier grad
und auch in den nächsten tagen bleibt es
trüb mit etwas schnee und etwas regen
welche folgen die korona krise für
deutschland hat damit geht es hier jetzt
gleich filmisch weiter wir wünschen
ihnen noch einen friedlichen
sonntagabend und freuen uns wenn sie
morgen wieder dabei
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]